foreign
the podcast entitled cereal docu-series
like making a murder and the staircase
were the hottest topics in pop culture
I was late to the serial Obsession but
when I dipped my toe in a few months
after its initial release I quickly Dove
head first into the exploding True Crime
world
I was obsessed
I have written a dissertation articles a
book and after countless hours consuming
True Crime
I'm still obsessed
as part of my research and my obsession
I attempted to quantify and categorize
true grant podcast just one tiny piece
of the exploding True Crime world
as of April 2022 and I did I had
identified nearly 5
000 and that number keeps growing
our obsession with True Crime isn't new
while Scholars generally credit Truman
capote's 1966 In Cold Blood as the birth
of True Crime media it's easy to find
examples that pre-date Capote by decades
consider the transatlantic Terror
inspired by Jack the Ripper and H.H
Holmes in the 1880s and 90s or how
Elizabeth Short's 1947
inspired lurid media frenzy and the
Black Dahlia lore
it could even be argued that public
executions in the Middle Ages
The Witch Trials even the Inquisition
were early examples of True Crime
entertainment then as now
Spectators would watch fascinated and
horrified at the intersections of good
and evil justice and Injustice played
out before them in Grim spectacles
it seems there is something innate in us
that is drawn to crimes or perceived
crimes
and your Associated Horrors
while I have always enjoyed both True
Crime and crime fiction my real
Obsession took off with the zeitgeist
I'm a multi-tasker so podcast felt made
for me
as I dove deeper down the serial Rabbit
Hole I began to expand my attention to
other True Crime narratives and I
noticed a new pattern emerging while
lots of creators were focused on
entertainment others were focused on
Criminal Justice Reform on wrongful
convictions on bringing attention to
Long Cold unsolved cases
I found this elating
so much so that I changed my whole
research stream to devote my time to
better understanding this particular
type of True Crime entertainment
but when they would have conversations
with other people about my obsession
especially people outside of True Crime
fandom
the same questions would emerge
is this okay
doesn't this feel icky are they laughing
about murders
I would shrug off those criticisms or
instead Point them towards what I
thought of as the good stuff to the
creators and storytellers who were
solving cases finding new leads drawing
attention to Long Cold cases and
injustices that's the good stuff
but when I would let myself look at the
ugly side of True Crime
it was really really ugly
in 2018 I started interviewing
storytellers journalists Advocates who
were involved in True Crime storytelling
I wanted to know how they personally
navigated this dichotomy I asked them to
Define True Crime and to talk about its
reputation
obviously they would gush about the good
stuff
but other words kept coming up
exploitative
salacious
print
murder porn
and just like the famous quote about
traditional pornography all of my
interviewees told me that while they
couldn't Define bad True Crime
they all knew it when they saw it
so today I am here to offer those of you
who like me might be a little obsessed
four questions to ask yourself about the
real world implications of your true
crime consumption
I've based these questions on from
talking to people involved in the
storytelling but also listening to
people who have been affected by their
tragic connections to these stories
it is my hope that by becoming more
mindful consumers of True Crime media we
can direct our Attention our resources
our dollars towards the people doing the
good work
so question number one ask yourself
why am I interested in this
no right answer to this question
multiple Studies have shown that true
crime fans particularly women are drawn
to the sense of community
so many of us have been ourselves
survivors or no other survivors and
victims of salt harassment even murder
hearing the stories of others can be
healing we can feel empowered to fight
back and feel less alone
on the other hand sometimes interest in
a true time story is driven by horror or
titillation or morbid curiosity while
those feelings are natural and they're
valid if that's the only reason that
you're interested in a story
it might be time to find something new
question number two
how does this make me feel
True Crime fans know that true crime is
rarely a feel-good story and yet
we still seek out that content
for some people the excitement and the
motivation are in learning about a new
topic for others there's what media
psychologists call a eutemonic
motivation
that is
we are interested for reasons Beyond
pleasure or hedonic motivation
for example in my own listening I've
known myself to finish a victim's story
not because it was well told or even
necessarily interesting to me but
because I felt like I owed attention
this since tragedy especially in the
case of victims who are less likely to
receive coverage in mainstream press
like black men or indigenous girls
on the other hand
sometimes interest is driven because
it's exciting because the story is
thrilling it's well produced it's filled
with fascinating characters
while those hedonic motivations are not
inherently problematic again
if that's the only reason you're
interested in a story
it might be time to reevaluate that
consumption
question number three
and this is a big one
how might the people involved in this
story feel
this can be a complicated question
take for example the ubiquitous cereal
case
advocates for Adnan Syed the man that
many believe is a victim of wrongful
conviction
have written books produced
documentaries and recorded hours and
hours of podcasts about the case
they frame their arguments in that they
are searching Justice not only for Adnan
but also for Heyman Lee the young girl
whose death is at the center of the
story
and yet while these are noble causes
Hayes family is famously absent from the
narratives and they've issued statements
saying that there are deep wounds that
this remediation of her story opens
does that make telling stay Hayes story
inherently unethical
not necessarily
True Crime storytelling much like
traditional journalism delves into
painful subjects
sometimes that means private citizens
public lives or private citizens lives
become public information
sometimes that means wounds are on a
reopened
criminologist Elizabeth Yardley has
written extensively about the ethics of
crime storytelling she urges True Crime
fans to remember in the words of a
Reddit post made by Hayman Lee's brother
to us
it's real life
Lee has criticized serial producers for
leaving his family out of these
narratives
in that Reddit post he goes on to say to
you
it's another murder mystery a crime
drama an episode of CSI
you weren't there to see your mom crying
every night
shame on you I hope that what happens to
us never happens to you and you have to
have your story
blasted to 5 million listeners
when discovering new True Crime
narratives ask yourself
are the people in this story being hurt
and if so is there a justifiable reason
to inflict that harm can some good come
from retelling the story
or is it just for entertainment
if the answer is the latter again
maybe time to find something new
and finally my last question to ask
yourself to make you
more aware of the real world impacts of
your true crime consumption is this
am I motivated to act
in my experience my favorites the things
I consider the really good stuff
they leave things in the dark and truth
and Justice and the inimitable
undisclosed podcast
they leave listeners with a mission
to donate
to contact a member of Congress
to work within our own communities for
healing for ourselves and for others
on the other hand most of the True Crime
that I find really questionable leaves
me feeling helpless or afraid
it focuses too much on the horrors or
the injustices and not enough on healing
or Solutions
there's a world of difference between a
Creator who plays a 9-1-1 call to
horrify his audience with anguish
screams and the one who plays a call in
hopes that someone will hear a clue
maybe a passing truck a Rushing Water
that helps find where a missing victim
disappeared
the ethical creators will draw these
lines around their motivations they will
remind their listeners
that looking through Court transcripts
could be helpful but harassing victims
family members or suspects online is not
while these four questions
how does this make me feel why am I
interested in this how might the people
involved feel
and does this motivate me to act can not
alone create a world of less
exploitative more ethical True Crime our
individual consumption has impacts
it is my hope that by directing our
attention to the people doing the good
stuff
that we can turn our time and our
dollars and our resources
we can use that ourselves as murderinos
as fans and amplify the potential for
good in our true Grime obsession
foreign